you know what you know what's really
crazy about everything's gone i i want
to clarify something too because we
talked about this a bit yesterday
spotify apparently never censored joe
rogan and alex jones
uh apparently what happened was
my understanding is it wasn't popping up
on people's feeds properly and they
tried re-uploading it
and then it just made it disappear on
everyone's feed but it was there just
labeled wrong or something
people people don't realize this happens
to me sometimes i'll like look at my
podcast numbers and it'll be low and
i'll go no and i'll look and there'll be
like one number
in like seasons or episode that moves it
incorrectly on a list and then people
can't find it we would have it minds man
a lot
a lot more than you'd realize like
people would upload stuff it would just
get go dark and we wouldn't we'd be like
oh it's something in the code like
there's so much complexity
however you're censoring me and it's
however 99 of the time i gotta say
how does it keep happening to joe i know
that like weird
all the episodes that didn't make it
over just happened to be
gavin mcinnes and then the one episode
and and joe actually said he's
like of all the episodes but anyway i
bring this up um for one to clarify
it's it's up it was on spotify it's
still up on spotify
but seeing all these lefties tweet
things about alex jones
and it's the funniest thing these people
are as dumb as a box of rocks
and that's an insult to a box of rocks
they're saying things like
how dare spotify allow alex jones to
harass this family
it's like joe joe didn't host alex jones
so that alex jones could harass a family
you don't know they didn't even bring it
up what family are you talking about the
sandy hook family oh my god
oh that's right seven years alex alex
jones did not go
on on joe rogan's show and start
screaming about this family
he's been very repentant about it
actually yeah and it happened what in
2012 2013 so yeah
the point is you look at what they did
to nick sandman
he smirked and you look at what they do
to alex jones how dare you allow him to
harass his family
it's like dude that was years ago he's
been sued over it he's apologized for it
and he's saying other things it's like
these people are so disingenuous they
expect me to
hold a grudge for the rest of my life
yeah what am i gonna do alex jones on
the street and be like how dare you
harass a family
and he's going to be like i'm i'm buying
milk
i'm just walking home yeah there's no
path to redemption right
they just want to take a snapshot of a
person in their worst moment and have
that represent them for the rest of
their lives but only if it's somebody
with whom they disagree of course
exactly do they
is i don't even think it's about that to
be honest why not i think
it's just tribalism no exactly something
they disagree with i think i think
you've got a lot of people who just want
to be angry
you know that comic where it's like i'm
angry and the guy's like here's the
solution
he's like i don't want a solution he
burns it i want to be angry classic
that's what it is
it's just something social media has
done to our brains i mean this is this
is part of human nature for us to want
to be angry and to want to find enemies
for whatever reason because we are
fallen but
i do think it's been exacerbated yes by
by our social media trends
like the fact that i think we talked
about this before on twitter
it's like when you have a bad day on
twitter it's because
somebody roasted you and when it's a
good day on twitter it's because you
roasted somebody else like
you're always it's you're being mean to
someone or someone's being mean to you
that's like 95 percent of what twitter
is
i disagree disagree really i think it's
well you're being mean to me
this falls into a very simple philosophy
when you wake up in the morning
do you say to yourself life is good or
do you say life is awful yeah
i wake up and i'm like time to get to
work take my you know pour myself a
coffee sit down and say i wonder what's
happening in the world today
actually when i wake up i'm just i pull
my phone up and i'm like they did what
last night in philadelphia
here's the coffee i'm like my eyes are
like squinting at the screen it's too
bright i'm like
they burned down what again and then a
few minutes later i'm like oh i get up
and uh you know and then i go to work
when tim wakes up he just screams and
punches the wall so hard it wakes
everyone up
it does every morning yeah it's just
ritual anyway the point is
i go on twitter i don't look at
notifications
i don't respond i sometimes respond to
people only if i end up seeing it for
some reason
i ignore notifications i ignore ads it's
a good strategy i just ignore everybody
there are some times where you know i'll
notice something for some reason but
it's rare
and then twitter is just great it's like
being a roller coaster that only goes
down
it's true you know you're like the whole
time ever
have you ever spent it just lost an hour
on twitter and been like you know what i
gained a lot from that like my life is
better i'm reading twitter all day
are you really i guess you i guess you
can help with your job like finding
stories i understand that like every
once in a while if i don't have an idea
for a video i'll look at what's trending
but i just i follow i i have a i have a
list of people i follow from left and
right journalists
and news organizations and i've got some
great journalists
that i follow that you know i see what
they what they're talking about and
follow and
then i track i check a bunch of
different news outlets periodically
their stories i stumble upon pertaining
to like censorship and tech and the
internet and things like that
well i guess i'm just projecting you use
twitter more responsibly than i do tim
you know i just use it i i i deleted
twitter when did you delete
like maybe a year and a half ago but i
deleted on my phone
i mean yeah yeah and then i was just
like now what i'll read them comments
for my name
and i do it like a social experiment
because i'm as an i studied acting since
i was like 15 i would like sit
at lunch at the college and just watch
people walk around and interact and just
study people study people all day study
people
so i'll study the comments and for when
they talk about me
or my i see my name as like a
representative of a idea
not i don't i de-personalize and i just
see these like
waves of the way people behave and it's
i laugh and i laugh it's just
so interesting that can drive you people
people you can't i'm already crazy
that's great i don't know if it's good
for your mental condition
anyway look the point of the point of
twitter is it's a rage machine
yes the average person doesn't have the
mental fortitude to withstand that kind
of
old man right yeah we let people use
twitter pretty young and then there are
people
it's funny because there are folks who
aren't even public figures but they'll
tweet something that goes viral and then
it's super controversial and everyone's
jumping on the bandwagon of criticizing
them it's like
i was reading a story about a woman who
tweeted something i can't remember what
it was but it was pretty tasteless and
she's just like a regular
personal lady in something in south
south africa or whatever i'm not sure i
know that she hopped on an airplane and
yeah the airplane landed her life was
ruined
hold on
that's right the joke was that it was
about white privilege
yeah she was joking that she had white
privilege therefore she wouldn't get
aids
she the way she phrased it was like i
read it and i was like i very
much understand that she is trying to
make a woke joke she's like making fun
of white people like oh don't like
people have it so great
right and they were like they didn't
care yeah they're like how dare you
and then she landed from her pl from her
flight and her phone's going
right right she said she got like a text
message and they're like are you okay
call me if you need anything she's like
what's happening and she was a nobody
yeah she was not she's had a couple
hundred followers there's also
every now and then you know you just
need to find a stranger to be angry at
there's a weird phenomenon
when someone gets famous off of a viral
tweet that they there's a tendency to
want to
keep doing that tweet over and over
again and you can drive people into
these crazy holes well yeah because the
last time you did it you got a massive
dopamine rush
because you got attention and so like
i'm gonna do it again
you're liking my tweets speaking of
which guys paypal.com slash freedom
paypal.com would you imagine if like
people
people acted the way that you know they
do on twitter but in real life so
they'd say something like yo ian sheamus
is dumb
paypal me at paypal that actually does
happen to me
when i go outside people will say that
whoever roasts me the best will get
venmoed something
no well i was thinking about this the
other day actually it's kind of like a
road rage
phenomena when you're driving and when
you're on the internet you're
interacting with humans in a way where
you're not really going to be held
accountable
so we let the worst part of ourselves be
exposed in a lot of those interactions
and so it's really sad but it it i don't
know if it actually causes the problem
so much as it reveals what's already
underneath
however once that that's been revealed i
think people habituate themselves
towards that because they can get away
with it more often so it does make you a
nastier person
but it starts by revealing the nastiness
that was already there and they know it
builds upon it and jack knows it
all right
when jack dorsey was on the the senate
hearing i guess apparently one of the
republicans asked him to name a single
liberal his platform is banned
and he couldn't do it
[Laughter]
i mean there i i couldn't they banned a
bunch of occupy wall street people
yeah that uh this was like a year two
like two years ago so
they've done it for sure he couldn't eat
anything he's like uh didn't they go
through anti-media
did you name him i'm pretty sure
anti-media got banned yeah i think it's
ridiculous
and and it's like these are leftist
activists of anti-war
and why are they so that the big story
with anti-media was pinterest that
veritas uncovered that
but on twitter i believe they also got
the acts as well as several occupy
accounts i think there really is like a
dark
uh un like thing in people's minds like
humans are like got this weird dark
fantasy and i only noticed it because
if you sometimes when you play video
games when i play video games or
dungeons and dragons with someone
they'll choose to be a real evil
character no
they're not i'll rip your stomach out
and eat it and i'm like what the
god no no no no no you're wrong i'll
stop you're there because i'm wrong
you're wrong i have to stop you because
there's a meme about this
where it's someone i can't remember
which open world the game it was
but it was like a guy playing a video
game and he's like i've just completed
the game as the hero
now i'm going to play as the villain
that's how i do it and then it shows a
guy saying like
this is you know he's like why why did
you kill my brother and then the person
sitting there crying like
i couldn't do it again so what i'm
trying to say is when people go evil
they quick save that's the joke like
when you're playing other scrolls
you'll quick save then go on and then
reload and be like okay
now that i got it out of my system and
i'm you know we're really nice to npcs
playing video games when we're on the
internet with strangers we're very much
not i'm really dude it's true like when
i try i i've tried i can't do evil play
throughs
i can't because you're good though i
don't think you have like a deep
psychosis like some of these people like
dude i'm playing skyrim
and i'm just like i'm holding the bow in
vr and i'm like i can't
shoot the looney speaking of vr but you
know what it is i got the other new
oculus
yeah yeah yeah just came out this is uh
just sort of a strange
failing of human empathy which is that
when you're playing that video game even
though there's not an actual person
there yeah
it appears as if there is one when
you're on the internet and you see that
doesn't actually feel like an avatar of
like a weird looking animal creature
yeah
or a twitter phenomenon there is a
person there but it doesn't seem like it
so
it actually leads you to be better to
computer generated images than you are
an actual human
well hold on maybe maybe it's because we
have this uh this darkness inside of us
a rage towards anime characters i think
that's part of it so it's like
they look so not it's obvious that anime
is a scourge
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you